If you go for a day,
you think it's 1, but it looks like 1,
but
that's three clouds
.  Yeah
That's what
Itsuki-chan hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha, Itsuki called Itsuki by the name of the name Itsuki
.
Well, you were the only one who couldn't figure out what was bothering you, so I was wondering if that was the case.
Knowing the song with a new voice In the
end, I can only discriminate in this way
But that's okay With this, the matter is settled
, your true identity is
Beep It can be
said that it's already love
Asama, why don't you even know yourself?